GREG: IN THE NEW PHASE OF THE
PANDEMIC, LET’S REVIEW WHAT WE
KNOW.
IT IS TRUE WE DON’T KNOW JACK
AND IT’S NOT OUR FAULT, IT’S
CALLED A NOVEL UNDER NOVEL VIRUS
AND IT’S A NOVEL AND A VIRUS
WHICH MEANS WE CANNOT SEE WHAT
WERE TALKING ABOUT, IT’S
INVISIBLE TO US AS TRUTH IS TO
CNN.
WHICH MAKES IT SCARY, HOW SCARY,
THEN YOUR TIME DID A PIECE ON
QUARANTINING WITH THE GHOST,
RATHER THAN FOCUS ON REAL STUFF,
THEY COVERED UNEXPLAINED
ACTIVITY DURING HOUSE ARREST,
SHAKING WINDOW SHADES, RATTLING
DOORKNOBS, COLD WATER IN THE
SHOWER AND JOE BIDEN IN THE
BASEMENT, OF COURSE SOMETIMES
HOUSES CREEK AND PLUMBING ACTS
WEIRD BUT THAT’S MY POST BURRITO
STOMACH, NOT A STORY SO HAS TO
BE A GHOST, THE LIGHT FLICKERED,
AND MUST BE A GHOST, I PUT MY
HOUSE KEYS AWAY, NOT THE FACT
THAT I BEEN DRINKING ALL DAY AND
EVERYTHING IS ON THE FLOOR
INCLUDING ME, I’M NOT SAYING
GOES DON’T EXIST, LOOK WHAT I
FOUND IN MY SOCK DRAWER.
LOOK, I GET IT, THE MOST LIKELY
EXPLANATION FROM SOMETHING THE
TRUTH DOES NOT GRAB YOU, THERE
IS NO STORY, A GHOST IS SO MUCH
MORE FUN THAN NOT A GHOST, WHO
CARES IF IT’S FALSE, THE ONLY
THING MISSING IS GENDER OR RACE,
ANTICIPATE A FOLLOW-UP PIECE
WITH OLD WHITE SEXES GHOST, I
SWEAR I SAW A GHOST AND HE
CHECKED OUT MY BREAST OR WORSE,
THE GHOST DID NOT CALL ME A
REESE’S NAME BUT I COULD TELL HE
VOTED FOR TRUMP, WHY CAN’T GHOST
BE RACIST OR SEXIST, ARE WE
ALREADY ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA,
WE DON’T NEED A POLE TO BE
HATEFUL, SEE DONALD TRUMP WHO
BLAMES CHINA FOR THE VIRUS.
>> YOU SAID THE U.S. IS DOING
FAR BETTER THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO TESTING
TESTING.
>> YES.
>> WHY DOES THAT MATTER, WHY IS
THIS GLOBAL IF EVERYDAY
AMERICANS ARE STILL LOSING THEIR
LIVES AND WERE STILL SEEING MORE
CASES EVERY DAY?
>> THEY ARE LOSING THEIR LIVES
EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND
MAYBE THAT’S A QUESTION YOU
SHOULD ASK CHINA.
>> WHY ARE YOU SAYING THAT TO ME
SPECIFICALLY.
>> I’M TELLING YOU, I’M NOT
SAYING AS SPECIFICALLY TO
ANYBODY, I’M SAYING TO ANYBODY
THAT WOULD ASK A NASTY QUESTION.
GREG: I LOVE IT, YOU KNOW WHERE
THIS WENT.
>> WE SAW IN THE EXCHANGE THAT
SOMETHING HAS RACIAL OVERTONES,
IT IS RACIST TO LOOK AT IN ASIAN
AMERICAN WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT AND SAID ASKED
CHINA.
GREG: FOR THE PILLSBURY DOUGH
BOY TO BELIEVE HIS OWN
DROPPINGS, HE HAS TO PRETEND THE
LAST FOUR YEARS OF THIS DID NOT
EXIST.
>> CHINA.
>> CHINA, TAINO INTERNET CAME
OUT OF CHINA.
GREG: WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
MEALS HE MISSES A LOT OF THINGS,
YOU WANT A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR,
HERE IT IS CLAIMING THE LIGHT
AND TURN RIGHT UP SEXES OVER
RUSSIA.
>> WERE LOOKING AT THE
RIGHT-WING MEDIA WHETHER SUCH AN
OBSESSION WITH THE DEEP STATE IN
THE RUSSIA PROBE.
GREG: SO DISAPPOINTED IN WITH
HIM TO SAY THAT WITHOUT PUKING,
HE MUST IGNORE THIS.
>> WHAT DISPUTANT HAVE ON TRUMP,
HAS TRUMP IN COMPROMISE?
>> THIS IS A LETTER OF INTENT
FOR THE PROPOSED TRUMP TOWER
MOSCOW.
>> SERIOUS PEOPLE IN AND OUT OF
GOVERNMENT ASKING WHETHER U.S.
PRESIDENT MIGHT BE AN UNWITTING
OR WOODEN RUSSIAN ASSET WERE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS AN AGENT OF A FOREIGN POWER
IN THE PRESIDENTS NO COLLUSION,
NO OBSTRUCTION MANTRA, WE KNOW
IT’S FALL.
>> DO YOU STILL BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT CAN BE A RUSSIAN
ASSET?
>> I THINK IT IS POSSIBLE.
GREG: WHEN CNN SAYS YOU’RE
OBSESSED IT’S LIKE A DRUNK
SAYING YOUR BREATH SMELLS OVER
HIM.
THERE IS SUCCESS RELIES ON NO
ONE ELSE HAVING A SHORT-TERM
MEMORY.
HERE IS CHRIS CUOMO BLAMING FOX
FOR FUTURE GUEST.
>> EVERYONE AROUND HIM HAS A
MASK ON, HE DOES IT BECAUSE HE
WANTS TO KEEP UP THE FOX FORCE,
THE BS THAT COVID-19 IS
OVERRATED.
I GUESS THE ANTI-ELITIST OVER
THERE ARE OKAY WITH 10000 MORE
DEAD.
GREG: HOW DOES THE BOZO GET AWAY
WITH THAT, I THINK HE HOPES YOU
FORGOT ABOUT THE THOUSANDS OF
REAL DEATHS WHICH HAPPENED UNDER
HIS BROTHERS WATCH, DURING THAT
TRAGEDY, WHAT DID CHRIS ASK HIS
BRO?
>> DO YOU THINK YOU ARE AN
ATTRACTIVE PERSON BECAUSE YOU’RE
SINGLE AND READY TO MINGLE?
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU ARE SOME
DESIRABLE PERSON AND THIS IS NOT
JUST PEOPLE’S PAIN COMING OUT OF
IT?
>> I HATE REHASHING THIS BUT
WHEN THAT JERK LAYS 10000 DEAD
BODIES ON US, WE HAVE TO SHOW
YOU THAT THE DEBT ALREADY EXIST
AND IT HITS A LITTLE CLOSER TO
HIS HOME FOR CHRIS THAN HE WOULD
LIKE TO ADMIT.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND WHEN SOMEONE
ACCUSES YOU OF WANTING DEATH
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO FEED YOUR
FAMILY BY GETTING BACK TO WORK,
SAY THIS, IF YOU WANT US TO STAY
INSIDE, YOU MUST LOVE’S SPOUSAL
ABUSE, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
SURGING UNDER THE SHUTDOWN, IS
IT TRUE THAT YOU LIKE TO SEE
MORE ABUSED SPOUSES CHRIS?
IT SOUNDS ABSURD BECAUSE IT IS
BUT THAT’S HOW THE MEDIA SMEARS
YOU PLUS THEY ALWAYS HAVE THE
ANSWERS BUT ONLY AFTER THE FACT
WHICH MAKES ME WONDER WHERE THE
HELL WERE YOU GUYS WHEN THIS
PANDEMIC STARTED, WHY DID YOU
HOLD OUT, IT’S CRIMINAL THAT YOU
HAVE THE ANSWER KEY, KEPT IT
HIDDEN UNTIL AFTER ALL THE
DEATH.
FACT IS ANYONE WHO SAYS THEY
KNOW IS FULL OF IT, NOT JUST THE
MEDIA BUT EXPERTS TOO, THEY GOT
SO MANY THINGS WRONG, MASKS,
SHUTTING DOWN TRAVEL,
VENTILATORS, BUT IF NO ONE KNOWS
ANYTHING, YOU MIGHT AS WELL
INVITE ANYONE TO DISCUSS A
PANDEMIC.
CNN HAD GRETA THUNBERG ON A
SPECIAL BECAUSE THEY PUT MORE
VALUE ON HER COOL WORDS THAN THE
ACTUAL VIRUS BRIEFINGS THEY
SKIPPED.
GRETA CITED THE IMPORTANCE OF
SCIENCE A STRONGMAN ARGUMENT
SAYING WHO IS NOT PRO-SCIENCE
AND LINKED IT TO HER CRUSADE
CLIMATE.
SHE PLEDGED 100 GRAND TO UNICEF
WHICH IS AWESOME, WHEN I WAS 17
ALL THEY HAD WAS A BB GUN AND A
STACK OF SWINK THAT I STORED IN
A TREE.
IF THIS IS THE TREND FOR CNN, I
CANNOT WAIT TO SEE WHO THEY
CHOOSE FIRST FUTURE SPECIALS.
THE 2020 ELECTION WITH GRETA
THUNBERG.
RACE IN AMERICA WITH GRETA
THUNBERG, ARE GHOST REAL WITH
GRETA THUNBERG.
BUT YOU KNOW THEY COULD DO
WORSE, HAVE YOU SEEN THE NIGHTLY
LINEUP, IT’S A STRANGE THING HOW
THEY KEEP TRYING TO MAKE THE
PANDEMIC POLITICAL, YOU CANNOT
BLAME TRUMP FOR THAT, HE SHUT
DOWN THE ECONOMY AND THEN HE
DOLED OUT TRILLIONS, NOW HE’S
DESPERATE TO REOPEN, WHAT
POLITICAL SIDE IS THAT, HE’S ALL
OVER THE PLACE JUST LIKE
AMERICA.
HERE’S HOW YOU KNOW THE NEW RED
VERSUS BLUE DIVISION IS BOGUS,
THE MEDIA CANNOT FIGURE OUT HOW
TO COVER THE STATES, THEY WANT
TO FIND FAILURE IN RED STATES
AND SUCCESSES AND BLUE STATES
AND CHEER, SO FAR THAT IS NOT
HAPPENING, ALSO THE RIGHT TENS
TO BE RISK IN THE LEFT IS
OPPOSITE, THOSE WHO WANT TO GO
BACK TO WORK ARE PRETRADE AS
RIGHT WING AND THOSE SCOLDING US
TO STAY IN AND DEFINITELY ARE
NOT.
SO THE SCRIPT IS FLIPPED,
MEANING IT’S NOT RIGHT VERSUS
LEFT, INSTEAD IS MEDIA VERSUS
TRUMP, WHATEVER HE IS FOR, THEY
HAVE TO BE AGAINST, AT LEAST ARE
DIFFERENT, SMARTER, YOU GET IT
IN A WORLD IN WHICH WE THINK
SOMETHING WE NEVER FACED WE ARE
LUCKY, WE HAVE 50 EXPERIMENTS
GOING ON AT ONCE IN EACH
EXPERIMENT CAN WIN A DOZEN MORE.
ESTATE CAN TRY OUT A PLANNED,
SOME MIGHT DO GREAT AND SOME
MIGHT NOT, WE CAN COMPARE IN
CONTRACT, CHEESE NANCE WITHOUT
TRYING, IT’S WHAT YOU WOULD DO
IF YOU DON’T HAVE THE RIGHT
ANSWER YET.
IDIOTS WOULD PREFER A ONE DAY
FOR THE WHOLE COUNTRY TO GO BACK
WHICH IS LIKE PLACING ALL OF
YOUR CHIPS ON ONE NUMBER AND
RELET BUT YOU LIKELY USE
EQUALIZE.
IT IS LIKE YOUR 401K, IT’S NOT
ALL ONE STOCK, IT’S A PORTFOLIO
TO HEDGE AGAINST RISK, IT IS
SMART AND UNAVOIDABLE.
WE ARE GOING TO LEARN A LOT, WE
WILL SEE THE TRUTH THAT HAVE
ELUDED US THESE PAST MONTHS, NO
MORE GHOST IT WILL BE BRAVE
AMERICANS GETTING UP AND GOING
TO WORK AND PROTECTING EACH
OTHER THE BEST THAT THEY CAN
WITH SIMPLE CONSIDERATION IN THE
KIND OF COMMON SENSE THAT
ELECTED TRUMP OVER HILLARY, IT’S
A GREAT AMERICAN CHALLENGE OF
YOUR LIFETIME, I THINK WE ARE
READY.
GREG: LET’S WELCOME TONIGHT’S
GUEST, YOU CANNOT LOSE WHEN HE
TALKS NEWS, WASHINGTON TIMES
EDITOR CHARLIE HURT.
HE HAS MORE SINGLES THAN A STRIP
CLUB ATM, SINGER-SONGWRITER AND
HOST OF THE PURSUE ON FOX NATION
JOHN RICH.
SHE’S INSPIRING AS SHE IS WIRY,
HOST OF SINCERELY CAT ON FOX
NATION KAT TIMPF.
IN EVERY VOTE HE IS ON BECOMES A
SUBMARINE, MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK
AND HOST ON FOX NATION TYRUS.
GREG: CHARLES WELCOME BACK, WHAT
DO YOU THINK OF THE SHAME AND
BLAME GAME YOU SEE AMONG THE
MEDIA?
CHARLIE: IT IS INCREDIBLE AND I
THINK YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT, THAT
MONOLOGUE SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
THE FEDERALIST PAPERS, IT’S A
PERFECT ENUNCIATION TO
FEDERALISM, IT’S WHAT THE
FOUNDERS INTENDED AND IS EXACTLY
HOW YOU GET THROUGH SOMETHING
LIKE A PANDEMIC, YET 50
EXPERIMENTS AND WE CANNOT JUST
ASSUME THAT EVERY GOVERNOR IN
AMERICA WANTS TO DO WHATEVER
THEY HAVE TO DO TO SAVE LIVES,
THERE’S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
IDEAS FOR DOING THAT AND WE CAN
PICK THE GOOD ONES AND LEARN
FROM THE BAD ONES.
BUT OF COURSE THE OTANI IS
BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO HATE TRUMP
AND TRUMP.
NO MATTER WHAT TRUMP DOES, THEY
HATE HIM AND YOU GET A REAL
SENSE THAT THEY’RE ROOTING FOR
FAILURE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE
TRUMP FAIL.
GREG: JOHN, IF YOU WANT TO
REOPEN YOUR RESTAURANT OR BAR,
PEOPLE WILL SAY YOU WANT PEOPLE
TO DIE.
THAT IS HOW THEY REASON.
JOHN: I HAD A TWEET THAT SAID
THAT TO ME TODAY BECAUSE WE
OPENED TODAY IN NASHVILLE, ALONG
WITH STATE AND CITY GUIDELINES
SOMEONE SAID JOHN RICH’S NEW
RECORD WILL BE CALLED I KILLED
MY FANS FOR MONEY, IT’S INSANITY
BUT YOU CAN’T LISTEN TO THE
NONSENSE BECAUSE WERE TRYING TO
GET OUR COUNTRY BACK OPEN SAFELY
JUST LIKE CHARLIE JUST SAID AND
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WERE DOING.
GREG: NO ONE KNOWS WHEN TO OPEN
AND NO ONE KNOWS ARE WE TOO
EARLY OR TOO LATE, THERE’S NO
EXACT DATE, THE ONLY WAY TO DO
IS TO FIND OUT WITH THE 50
OPENINGS AND SEE THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE STATES IN THE VIRUS,
THAT’S WHAT WE HAVE TO DO RIGHT?
KAT: I DISAGREE I THINK WE NEED
TO REMAIN CLOSED INDEFINITELY
AND FOCUS ON CALLING TRUMP RACES
OVER ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING,
THAT’S REALLY IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY LIKE THIS AND I’M SO
GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE, CHINA HAS BEEN
COVERING UP THE SEVERITY OF THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS FOR A WHILE
NOW AND WHY DO PEOPLE COVER
THINGS UP TO MAKE THEMSELVES
LOOK BETTER, WHAT IS IT TO MAKE
YOURSELF LOOK BETTER, ENGAGING
COMPETITION.
THAT IS CLEARLY WHAT HE MEANT,
YOU DON’T NEED A PHD IN SOCIAL
JUSTICE TO FIGURE THAT OUT, YOU
NEED A DICTIONARY AND THE
ABILITY TO READ, HE WAS MAKING A
POINT WORTH MAKING SO WHAT
SHOULD HE HAVE DONE, HE
SHOULD’VE SAID YOU ARE CHINESE,
I CANNOT ANSWER THAT, YOU ASKED
ME THAT BUT IF A WHITE REPORTER
ASKED ME, THEN I CAN TOTALLY
ANSWER.
WHAT DOES HE WANT PEOPLE TO DO
OR WHAT IS HE WANT HIM TO DO?
GREG: I CANNOT ANSWER THAT,
TYRUS, THIS IS A GREAT NEW WORLD
AND WE HAVE THE MEDIA THAT IS
COPYING ON OUR CITIZENS FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL CONCERNED, THEY’RE
NOT CUTTING THEM ANY SLACK WHICH
DRIVES ME CRAZY.
I KNOW IT’S NOT A QUESTION.
TYRUS: YES IT WAS A STATEMENT, I
GOT YOU.
THE THING ABOUT IT, WE HAVE TO
MAKE DECISIONS AND PERSONAL
INDIVIDUAL DECISIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THAT THE WHOLE POINT
TO BE AN AMERICAN, WE HAVE THE
GUIDELINES FROM THE CDC AND
THINGS WE CAN DO BUT WE KNOW
THAT THERE SHARKS IN THE WATER
AND WHETHER WE STANDARDS OR GO
OUTDOORS, WE WILL RUN THE RISK,
WE CAN TAKE PRECAUTIONS AND MAKE
THAT DECISION BUT WE NEED TO BE
ALLOWED TO MAKE THAT DECISION,
FOR ME AND WANTS TO OPEN UP HIS
RESTAURANT UNDER THOSE
GUIDELINES AND I DECIDE TO GO TO
HIS RESTAURANT BECAUSE THEN
FOLLOW MY GUIDELINES AND TAKE
THAT CHANCE, THERE SHOULD BE NO
ARGUMENT FOR THAT.
THAT SHOULD BE FINE, WE KNOW
WHAT’S GOING ON, WHENEVER THEY
TRY TO MAKE MEDICINE, SCIENCE